[拍手]
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
ちょっと間がこれちゃ
ありがとうございます8作エロ太郎
the pork ラバーと書いてありますけれどもまずこのトークラバール話をする
前にですねこのトーク大学の話をしたいと思います
僕が14歳の時ですこのトーク大学には外服従の留学生の方々そして客員教授の方々が
進む
三城町に留学生会館という施設があります
実は私はその近くの
で生まれまして中学校は仙台市立第四中学校という本で隣のところに通ったんです
けれども
実はですねそこで決定的は私の人生を決定づける出会いがありました
100円教授の方々には息子さん娘さんがやはりいるわけですね
て同じくらいの実は14歳のですね
その時は実はポーランドから来たパト率やという女性に出会いましたまあ女の子と言っ
ていいんですけれども
また美人なんですよ
[音楽]
中学校2年生にとっては本当にショッキングが出来事でした
みたいですか
見たい人
見せましょうほら
ね
これはダサいすよねー
いつの時代ですからこれ食べてこれ中これから頭であって2013年後なんです末市
バス遺族から今は亡き
で僕の14歳15歳の遍歴が書いております
また話で行って英語の壁にぶつかるわけです彼女は日本は全くなってませんでした
しかし英語しゃべれ感です僕はその時中学校2年生
中学2年生の日本人の英語分かりますねどれであるものなのか
アポてみたいなもんですよ
そんな時彼女がやはり私をヘルプしてくれましたどうやったら英語が通じること英語の
楽しみを教えてくれたんです
でそうで勝ち決意したんですねアメリカに行きたいってもっと英語を上手くなりたいっ
て
そして僕は15歳の時アメリカシアトルに行くことにしました
なりしたかったにそれ北アメリカでね英語僕の間からた後でもう一つ
プローブ行きたかったんですよ
5 pro 振ってある一番最後ので卒業式土器いるタクシーとの
あれ出なかったんですよで月郁郎今でしょ
っていう話だったんですよね手で行ったほうがいいんですけどアメリカの洗礼を受け
ます
色よる相撲疎かったですん
財布盗まれたもの
安いスウォッチの時計を盗まれました
その後
walk ば盗まれました
車に詰まりました
見つかったですけどボロボロでねー
そういう盗まれたんですけどそこでやはりその世界の日本の安全約日本が特殊だったん
ですがやっぱりね
財布な古酒と持ってくるっていうじゃないですかでも世界に出たのでそれ普通じゃない
ん
逆に日本が普通じゃない向こうが普通でもそんなことがあってもアメリカでは本当に
貴重はたくさんたくさんお友達ができている
ですねどうか本当アメリカの3年間の生活を満喫しました
しかし子黒子アメリカの生活はあの大乱戦ここで終わんないんですというのもアメリカ
お土産年間見た僕はですね
次の
もっと広い世界を見てみたかったヨーロッパに行ったんです次です
まず最初に僕はアメリカに行ったあと18歳でイギリスり
迎えます
これ作ったんですこれ
思ってねシアトルに行った僕はロンドこれ
ちょっと進めてきましたね
ロンドンに行った僕は4年巨大部に通いますその後最初の就職先は同一だったんです
先ほど4カ国語しゃべるなんていう音なんかブラフがありましたけれども
佐伯樹洞地区を忘れています
ですが相当52年半ほど畑と it 会社で働いた後ですね私は何を持った顔
段差になりたかったです国
実は千鳥ダンスカンパニーとダンスカンパニーずっと1年間さ属しておりました
ね今はちょっとお肉が若干なんですけれども
そんな形でそれ市で位置取りはワーキングホリデーに行きましたので
1年間とここでもどって来るんですけれども実はこの中で私決定的なまたもう一つの
出会いがありますフォトエッチの次
ロンドンにいる時でしたロンドン大学行ったんですけれども大学の時に私の友人で
モロッコ人のアホ別途君という友達がいたんです誰が僕にこう言うんです
モロっぽいより債務ロック4以上の国はないと
モロッコが世界で最高のクエである
モロッコや美味しい食べ物6個料理おいしいものはない
モロッコよりも素晴らしい景色はないのロックよりも素晴らしい人たちはいない
モロッコって僕その時国の価値って経済誌人だと思ってたんですよ
gdp その時 gnp ですかねがなんとなくにどえらい人だと思っていました
だからその時日本になったんですね世界で
その話を聞いてなんだこいつ何言ってんだと思いました
でも
彼に対して僕実は言い返す言葉がなかったんですよ
日本が日本よりも多い g 食べ物はない
日本よりも多い c 景色はない日本より素晴らしいたじゃいないって自信を持って
言えなかったんですよ僕はいえた言葉これ僕らトヨタとホンダがあります
これだけでした
その時僕思ったんですよ自分と自分の故郷を超えだけ誇ることができる彼はできている
た絵の価値だって
それで僕日本に戻るんです
自分が日本人だというアイデンティティーを
北10年海外行ってるんですよねこの10年間で僕が忘れていたものを取り戻すために
この日本に戻りました
東京に戻りました
なかなかで10年間の海外にずっとおかしくなったらたマネー
日本人の中日本女性かつ入っていけないんですよだから僕は死んだね日本東京のまずは
銀行証券会社に入って32歳の時にこのライフブリスと今の現在の会社を立ち上げます
この会社を立ち上げた理由はただ一つ
この東北を世界のその魅力を世界の皆さんに知ってもらうということです
この東北どれだけ皆さんにしてもらってますかね
これが遠くなく日本の頭なんですけれども
外国人が日本に来た数です
2010年からかけていました2011年は震災がありましたらちょっと下がってい
ます
でも見てください29パー47パー21パーというふうにどんどんどんどん戸びっ
ています去年2016年は2400万人の
外国人の方々がこの日本に訪れました
さてここで問題です
遠くのまで付くを出していきましょう
実は江東区なんですよ青森岩手宮城秋田山形福島ロー6億6件となっていますけれども
実は震災前と比べると
まあアフター福島ちょっと覗くとですねだいたい増えてるんですよ
すごく増えています皆さんこれ質問があります
日本全体力停留外国人100%とした時にこのトーク6件には何にしてると思います
みなさん
何パーセントかいきますよ50%半分だ東北に来ているしたことがある
爆発しませんよね
奈良
ろっ
さーん
に良い
h
知ってる方結構いるんですね閉店9%なんですよ
東クロッケ合わせてもですよこの状況何とかしたかったというのが何とかしたい今でも
これが私が今今今もこの会社を存続し続けている理由です
でただこれを実現するためにはもっと人来てくれるためには僕はよ力だけじゃダメなん
です
だって一つか会社ないんだろうセンターに高いじゃないんですよ
力が欲しかったただ僕がこういうふうにつけたんです東北にもっと人を呼びたいもっと
人を世界中で呼びたいんですとそしたら面白いことにその目標を聞いた人たちが
いろんな人を紹介し
くれるんですよあいつ桜のアブ青森と面白いことしてるぞ
i 当てたりすごいことをやっているか櫻井さで紹介したい
僕はこんなことを言っていたら aiff と仕事をするといいことが起こるかもしれ
ないと多くにそんな試合がありました
そこで僕は何があったかというと
東北いいアウトバウンド連合と一般社団法人を遠く6件
15社で立ち上げることにしました
これはどういうことかというと東北で観光に取り組んでいる
15の会社が同じをが同じ目的
東北に人を呼び込もうということで立ち上げた会社です
実はこれかこの目的なんですけれども観光という力を誓っ使って社会問題が解決して
いこう
どんな問題なのか
少子高齢化
田舎と都会の給与のさそういうものを
インバウンドという害悪中観光客を使ってこの問題を解決志向としていこうとそんな
思いで立ち上げました
どんなことやってるのか
みなさんにご紹介したい僕らがいろんなツアーを作っています
最初にご紹介者の声です
青森県してますみなさん
[音楽]
日本で一番寿命が短いんですよ
1わかりますこれ
寿命が短い青森県人の太くて短い人生を味わうじゃないかと
短命県体験ツアーこんなものを作っています家でこの団体では
弘前団です場所は
どんなものが見たいですこのつはみたいって言ってはいありがとうございます
真冬にあるんですよちょっと見えてますでもうね
朝10時に出発してるのに
10時半から酒倉入ってますよねこんな感じです
朝10時半の光景です
ノンパラって酔っ払っても飲んでご飲んだくれでこの酔っ払ってる状態で起きるになり
ますお昼は
アーネ津軽名物の腰にも白ラーメですよこれ先ほど壁でありもありましたけれども
煮干しラーメンでもなぜ青森県時短命なんですから目食べるのに
ループ喉からですよ
テープドン二弾これで実はこの通話を着てなんて全部とってくださってるんですよ
でもね青森県事項だけではないですよもういっぱい食べさせられちゃう
味濃いやつちょっとで濃いやつまたスープ疑っ
こんなことなんですよでね酔っ払っても食べてますよね酔っ払ってもこう郡山結構時間
たその後リアの伝統工芸の体験酔っ払ったままであるんですけど
その後李で旅館に行きます旅館にも8時半くらいチェックいいなんですよ
酔っ払ってるからもやれることをやることないんでやりたくないんでねそうするともう
布団が敷かれているんです
横&布団普通は旅館というのはチェックイン時は6アルフとしてませんよね
そうすると布団が敷いてあってよテーブルが横に避けられていますそのテーブルの上
なんと
また
衣装便と人間失格
そんなツアーがあるわけですよの中に
僕らは何をしたいのか
今実は東北というところは0.9%ですよこのこの状態をどうすればいいのかというと
北海道にもない
東京にもない九州にもないものを作っているわけないですよ
みんな言うんですとー黒いで教えてください山の幸が美味しくって
海のたちが美味しくって温泉があって
ですよねそんなもんどこでも染まり日本人はに方は
東北にしかないボールをやっていくんですよたこのほかでいっぱいなんでしょ
また切って知ってますねあさくまを打つ人らしいですよまた切って処理や番中山たけ
トレッキングとかね
あるんですよアトレある居酒屋ば通うスナック貼ったり周りで
やバーホッピングとかねいろいろあるんですよそういうもので東北れしかできないもの
をしっかりと
人をからめていくんですこの実はこのいえば1青森県民という気持ちになる
パーホッピングといってもスナックのママにちゃんとお話をする
マタギという人暮らしぶりということを体験してもらうことが実は私たちが千葉東北で
やらなくちゃいけないこと新しい建物を作るとかじゃないんですよ
今あるものをどうやっていく阿部どうやって生かしていくのか
そんなことを僕らは捉えをしています
さあとはいえがよくでたくさん来たら頭を送りしたら皆さんビックリしません日本人の
方々
緊張しませんなぜ近所数ですかねえ英語しゃべれないからですよ英語喋るなきゃって
思うから日本人はこうなんですがーで外国人が日本に来て一番ショッカーショップが
出来事
道を聞こうとしたら逃げられた
向かって言ったら俯かれたそんなことがたくさんあるだから僕はこう考えないですまず
皆さんの心のファー度を下げようって皆さんがしっかりと外は口の形た時
ウェルカムできる心をつくってしまうって
レストアってこんな文章があります
ありますよねレストランで願い9時の方はこう注文した後に以上に薄い子か言うじゃ
なく日本語で
こういう風な教え方をすれば皆さん英語を簡単に喋れるじゃないかなと思ってこれ偽り
綺麗なんですけれども出していました
野菜色で宜しいでしょうかったら英語でなんてか知っています皆さん
こういうんですよねっ
日本人の発音だと
米しましょう性の良い
that さすが上手いですね
でもねこれはで1億3000万人の日本人の相対した通じな英語なんですよ
ですよね発音が日本語だから
じゃあ
別が言い方があるんじゃないか
いきますよ
これから皆さんに一瞬でネイティブスピーカーになっていただきます
ほら
あれなんだごめん楽しいですよねいいですかこのまま読んでください最後喰種まあ
ください後押し上げてくださいできますせーの
ねえてる
ありがとうございますあるん
心のハードルを下げるんですよ皆さんが必要なことはこれを駅弁の売ってるおばあ
ちゃんが言ったら皆さん一発数十台ですえーんはしゃべればいいんですよ
しゃべない1人でも英語をしゃべってもらえる心を作るためには頭だけ簡単に教えて
こいつぁ鳥さん塾欄で30
高ユーロは1
パンです今日で鹿がと興奮してる子ってなんでできないんですけれども
ということで私たちは何をしたいのか私誰をしなきゃいけないのか
東北が五福神は関係ない自治体は宮城県とか青森系とか関係な面白いボラーレが
たくさんいくんですよ
キツネ村があれば行くんです面白いから
そして僕らはしなきゃいけないこと犬じゃなくってお互いが東北のため同氏が飽きたり
いったらそこ絶対行ったほうがいいよ
青森たこ絶対た方がいいよ b 美上げてきたらあそこの球体や行ったほうがいいよ
って
お互いがお互いあることを褒め合うことで外国人の語りもどこ行ったらいいのあそこ
行ったほうがいいよみんなを言えるになるんです
そして最後興味去ったオフィスのがたくさんいます
ぜひ教育大学高校中学校小学校の方にもそういう
とうとう空魅力ということをお互い話すように英語力措置大切なんですよ
日本の歴史日本の文化日本の地位日本の祭りそういうことをしっかりとば欄で行くこと
が実は真の国際化だと言う
ふうに思っています本日はありがとうございましたん